-Jimmy Buffett, we love you.
Thank you so much for coming on.
-Jimmy Fallon.
-I know,
Jimmy and Jimmy right here.
-Right, yeah.
-Thank you for singing
"Margaritaville"
earlier in the show.
-Let's talk about
Florence Welch, huh?
-I mean,
can we just talk about that?
-Doing "Margaritaville."
Come on, please.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-She's got everything, right?
She's got the voice.
-I know.
That was, like, angelic kind of.
-Yeah, take that on tour.
You were saying backstage, I go,
"Thanks for doing the bit,"
and you go,
"Yeah, well,
I sang 'Margaritaville'
for the first time on
"The Tonight Show."
-That's right.
-With Johnny Carson.
-Yeah, 41 years ago.
[ Cheers and applause ]
41 years?
Oh, oh!
-I have a photo of it.
-Oh, my God.
-Here's a picture of you
and Johnny, right there.
[ Applause ]
-Oh, that mustache.
No wonder it went.
-Look at that mustache.
I think you look like a stud.
Come on, bud.
-No, that's a little
porn-looking mustache.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, no.
-No, I never -- no.
-41 years ago.
This song has stood
the test of time.
-It has.
-Do you remember
going on "Carson"?
-Oh, yes. Yes.
-What was it --
-It was a transitional time
between, like --
Most of the acts before,
there were Vegas acts
and people Johnny knew or liked.
And I guess the network probably
was pushing
rock and roll in there.
So I studied it for like two
weeks like it was a course,
'cause I wanted
to know every move,
and I wanted to know who was
good, who could talk, and who --
Because he was a straight man.
You know that.
-Of course, yeah, exactly.
Johnny would set you up, and...
-And so
they had Jimi Hendrix on,
and Jimi Hendrix had bad trouble
with whatever the sound was,
and he stopped
in the middle of the song.
And then started again.
So it was like
a transitional point.
When I got on, they were not
very kind of friendly to me.
They said, "Listen,
the one thing you can't do
is stop because Johnny
doesn't like it when you stop."
And so I'd studied, I said,
"Well, I'm gonna do
'Margaritaville,'"
and then he said, you know,
"You'll never go to the desk.
Maybe he does it sometimes.
But in case he waves you,
then you walk over.
But it's not gonna happen."
[ Laughter ]
-"Anyway, thanks for being
here," yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, "Get out of here."
Good luck." Yeah.
-So I said, "Okay."
I was just happy to be on
"The Tonight Show."
I mean, come on.
I'd studied it.
So what I forgot about was,
the good thing was,
there were Parrot Heads
in the audience.
-Aha.
-Got any out here now?
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, thank God,
they're still here!
-Of course, they're everywhere.
-But they started yelling.
And Johnny kind of caught on
to the fact that there was
a crowd there.
And so, me, I didn't know
that much about television,
so I'm playing to the audience
and never look into the camera.
That's the first one.
So -- But when we started
the song, we were off tempo
because the crowd
was yelling so much.
So I basically [bleep] up
"Margaritaville"
on the "Johnny Carson Show."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh!
But did you -- did you stop?
-No.
-That's exactly right!
That's the lesson learned --
never stop.
-No, as the band knows,
there's an old credo is,
"When you get lost,
meet me on one," right?
-Yeah.
-So we got on one, we did it,
and then I [bleep] up --
I'm going,
"This is never gonna happen."
I looked, and he was going --
-He waved you over.
-And I went over, and I was
lucky enough to do that show.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How many times?
-I think 15 or 16 times.
Then he actually invited me
on the last week.
What a great guy.
And just a pro.
-Became friends with him.
-Yeah, but I'm --
That's so weird.
I'm getting goose bumps.
41 years later, I'm still on
"The Tonight Show."
-Yeah, but come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now you get an intro
with the "one and only."
Now you're the one and only
Jimmy Buffett.
You know, I love you so much
because you're just a performer,
and you're an artist,
and you need the audience.
-Yeah.
-And when the pandemic hit,
I really thought of you --
you're one of the first people
I thought of, because I go,
"He must be going insane."
'Cause you love to perform.
You don't stop.
-Absolutely.
Above anything
that I've been lucky enough
to do,
performing is what I love to do.
But I also, as a sailor,
I have been on
some rough voyages, and you just
have to keep going that way.
And so I just kind of --
you know, I had to take that
kind of sailor mentality
to steer through
the bad currents
that were going on.
So what we were lucky enough to
do, because we had already had
Radio Margaritaville,
we had Margaritaville TV,
and my daughter, who was doing
filmmaking at the time,
got me saying,
"Well, you got to just
play to people
on both of those things."
So we stayed in touch
with our audience
on Radio Margaritaville,
Margaritaville TV.
People that were still working
and first responders
and people in hospitals,
and people got on.
At least we were
staying in touch,
but we weren't
physically in touch.
So physically in touch came --
the first show was 10 tables,
four people to a table,
at a place called Belly Up
down in Southern California.
-Now you really made it.
[ Laughter ]
-I said, "Am I back
to the beginning?"
-Belly Up --
that's a great name.
-Was I time traveling
in the other direction?
-40 people, and you go, "Wow."
-And so what it was --
And we went to rehearsal before
that so three of us were in --
in California, and two of us
were in New York,
and they Zoomed in.
And the three of us
in California were in my piano
player Mike Utley's apartment,
and we started to play,
and we broke down crying,
it was that emotional.
We hadn't seen each other --
because that's the other family.
-Exactly.
-And so at least we did it then
because when we got in front
of the 40 people,
they started crying immediately.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah!
"Because we missed it."
-They missed it so much.
So we went from 40 people
initially and tried to
work our way up safely,
and then last --
Sunday night, we played to
60,000 people in New Orleans.
-That's what I'm talking about.
Come on.
We're coming back.
-Thank you.
-We're coming back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
New Orleans.
-In New Orleans, yeah.
-Now, that's a place
right there, New Orleans.
When you play there, I mean, if
you crush there, you've made it.
-Yeah.
-Because that's the good crowd.
That's a good spirit
right there.
-I started out on Bourbon Street
as a folk singer.
-You did?
-Yes.
-Wow.
What was that?
-Well, I was working, and --
There was a lot more music
on Bourbon Street then
than there was
the latest attractions.
[ Laughter ]
And so all the musicians
that I really loved,
jazz and other people,
were there.
And I worked in a little place
called The Bayou Room
for kind of a lower-level
Mafia pair of brothers.
And, uh --
[ Laughter ]
And so I was just so happy
to be there,
and I made $150 a week
and half price on drinks.
And the first week,
I owed them money.
[ Laughter ]
-That's legendary.
Come on, that is legendary.
-I got into it.
Listen, as an ex-Catholic
altar boy, I went hard.
-Yeah, right, yeah, yeah.
-But I did start there.
And that was really
my musical roots
came in New Orleans.
And I've stayed connected
to that
for as long as I've been here.
-let's talk about your new
documentary,
"Jazzfest: A New Orleans Story."
I mean, Jazzfest is legendary,
but I don't know if anyone knows
the history
and the story behind it.
-You know, to me, I think,
Jimmy, what starts it,
Jazzfest is like the child of
Mardi Gras, you know?
'Cause I grew up
as a child of Mardi Gras,
because you were allowed --
You know,
fun is important in this world.
-Thank you.
-As we're learning now,
when you see audiences
coming back,
they're so amped up to just see
a performance.
-It's the greatest.
There's nothing like it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's tough for us
not to get emotional.
-And so Jazzfest, I think I went
to the third or fourth one.
And our other friend,
Quint Davis, who helped,
who was instrumental in finding
the right musicians
for the documentary
with Frank Marshall,
he ran a little head shop called
The Love Shop, and we met then,
when I was going in
to buy papers.
And so --
-Not newspapers.
-No, not newspapers.
[ Laughter ]
So I experienced my whole
kind of musical beginnings
on Bourbon Street
and in New Orleans,
and so I went to the festival
that early and continued
just to go until they asked me
to come play it,
and that was like 20 years ago.
I played it
pretty much ever since.
-It's pretty fun
It's actually beautiful.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Jimmy Buffett
in "Jazzfest:
A New Orleans Story."
Take a look at this.
-I grew up on the Gulf Coast.
I was an 18-year-old
virgin Jesuit altar boy,
and I came to New Orleans
to not be that.
♪ I come here each season ♪
We couldn't get to California,
so we kind of hippied out
right here in New Orleans.
♪♪
♪ But it's a real beauty ♪
♪ Oh, these Louisiana cuties ♪
♪ And I know I got cutie that
slid over from Mississippi ♪
♪ And got a clue ♪
Everything about the songs,
I heard the melodies,
and the rhythms that I loved
came out of here.
♪ Again in Margaritaville ♪
-Oh, my goodness.
Jimmy Buffett, everybody.
-Thank you.
-Always good to see you.
Go see "Jazzfest:
A New Orleans Story."
Florence + The Machine perform
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
Jimmy Buffett!